-Eddie! Oh, look at you.
-Hey, Jimmy, how are you?
-Last time I saw you, by the
way, you and your wife just had
another baby, so now
you have two kids now.
How old are they now?
-So, we have Iris, who's 4,
and Luke, who is 2.
-Geez. And where have you been
for the last few months?
-Do you know,
we've been really lucky.
We've been -- Fortunately
everyone has remained healthy.
Until I just started
shooting again,
we were in the countryside,
which was wonderful.
There was space
for the kids to play.
We basically -- We sort of
became like an animal sanctuary
while we were there,
which was --
-A lot of people have done this.
I have a lot of friends
that have done this.
Did you get, like -- Did you
get -- Did you get chickens?
-I mean, we are basically
a parody of lockdown.
We do have chickens.
We have five chickens
whom my daughter named.
They're called Belinda,
Sally Henny Penny,
Blanket, Flower, and Henry.
-[ Laughs ]
-And they arrived,
and they had come from -- they
were sort of battery chickens,
so they didn't look that well,
but we kind of nurtured them
to health,
and I spent most of lockdown
running into other people's
gardens, trying to sort of
retrieve chickens
that were causing havoc.
-[ Laughs ] That's wild.
-My wife took
great satisfaction from it
because she basically on day one
kind of just bought me a drill
and gave me a drill,
and just kind of said,
"Here. Learn how to use that.
Build me a chicken hutch."
And so I built a chicken hutch,
which is like a triumphant --
-You built it yourself?
-I did build it.
I mean, it was kind of
flat-packed, so I --
and I succeeded in
kind of the bit
where the air
was meant to come in.
I got a bit wrong,
so I ended up having to drill
holes around it, but genuinely
the amount of pride
having built a chicken hutch
gave me
was sort of overwhelming.
-I just have pride
because I own a drill.
I've never used it,
but I own it.
I go, "I know where it is."
-I completely agree.
-I can tell you
exactly where it is.
I think I have to charge it up
before I use it,
but the fact that I own it,
I go,
"If you ever need me to drill
anything, honey."
She's like, "I'm good."
-I've got it.
The second you get into
drilling, it's just like
the most satisfying thing
in the world.
-You want to drill everything.
-I was sort of walking around,
drilling random holes
in random walls just because
it gave me some odd pleasure.
-Did the chickens --
Do they lay eggs?
-The chickens --
You know, they started off
not being that keen
for laying eggs.
They were kind of molting
and not that happy,
and gradually,
as they kind of fed well,
they ended up laying
tons of eggs,
which is great except for
the fact that I loathe eggs.
I kind of hate eggs.
So I would sort of have to carry
these eggs in, in the morning.
Sort of not really wanting --
but doing that thing you do with
your children.
-[ Retching ]
Just take it away.
-We were adopted by two
stray cats during lockdown,
as in these two very beautiful
black cats just came and started
purring at our door, and so
again, my daughter named them.
One she called Catty Redman.
And then the other one,
who had slightly spiky ears
and looked a bit terrifying,
she called Scary Catty Redman.
So Scary Catty Redman
and Catty Redman then ended up,
of course, coming into the house
and everything,
which is all great, except for
I'm deeply allergic to cats.
And so this sort of cat allergy,
egg, animal sanctuary thing
was wonderful in theory but
slightly stressful in reality.
-Dad of the year.
I'll give you props for that.
I could not go near --
I am allergic to cats too.
-Are you really?
There you go, Jimmy.
-Yeah. We should be roommates.
[ Laughter ]
So you just started a production
on "The Fantastic Beasts."
-Yeah, yes.
-How is everything going there?
-Well, we'd done a day of
shooting before COVID-19
really hit the U.K. proper.
So we started on a Friday and
then on a Sunday night it all --
we were all told to go home.
And then just a few weeks ago
we started again,
and it's a different world,
but we're so lucky to be back
in work, and it's interesting.
It's kind of like --
Film crews are amazing people.
And they're very adaptable
people, and so we have --
there's a lot of testing.
There is --
You know, we're in bubbles
and we're all masked, but it's
been kind of --
To begin with, I thought
how is this going to be?
And this ended up being
actually kind of great.
So it's nice to be back at work.
I feel very lucky.
-You come on my show normally to
talk about "Fantastic Beasts,"
but always it's so secretive.
-Yeah. Very secretive.
-You're not even allowed
to tell me what it's about.
But you showed me
a trick or a move before.
Can you tell us
something about this one?
-Do you know what?
Genuinely I'm not being,
like, sycophantic,
but one of the, like,
joys of promoting
a "Fantastic Beasts" movie is
getting to come and force you
to do some
ridiculous dance move.
It did cross my mind.
I can't tell you
anything about the new film,
otherwise I'll -- you know,
someone will get furious,
but there is a moment which I've
been sort of working on
and hoping will remain
in the film
and which I have been trying to
find some sort of
dinky little thing
that I can teach you to add.
So I mean, I can't --
I couldn't do it now,
but I'm hoping that come
November, we'll have another --
we can add one more move.
We should go dancing one night
and just beast
those "Fantastic Beasts"
moves out.
-Deal. I will do that with you.
Virtual handshake on that, yeah.
Or elbow bump.
I would totally do that
with you.
I will go dancing with you
whenever.
That's the best.
I want to talk about
"The Trial of the Chicago 7."
Can you stick around
and we can talk about that?
-I would love that, man.
-Awesome. More with
Eddie Redmayne, everybody.
♪ -I get the job done ♪